[Music]
[Applause]
diseased and malnourished screaming with
pain this little boys Bluetooth stomach
is full of parasites - what's wrong with
this baby listening the inside and also
warming in this time and they smell nice
his family escaped the slaughter in
Myanmar joining the exodus to Bangladesh
[Music]
there are thousands of sick children
here they're being treated by volunteer
doctors barely out of medical school
they're overwhelmed he escaped ease as
well scabies is malnourished he has
worms is vomiting through that yes yes
common infection
and you're seeing so many of these
children skin infection he's a very sick
boy looking his eyes saying he's icing
you can say here's also some less even
Amir and also the addition and he's also
a lethargy can he be given a bed in a
clinic because that's what he needs
yes faith or other things that we have
there are no hospital beds available
available bed are not available there is
so much people so must you let me see
you till then this is the scale of the
problem facing those young medics
kuttappa long refugee camp is a
sprawling massive in humanity but from
the sky this tarpaulin mosaic belies the
hell below
[Music]
more than half a million Rohingya have
fled a brutal crackdown on Myanmar
village this is just one part of one
camp aid has finally arrived these lines
for handouts of growing longer because
thousands more a hinga come by the day
this flow of human misery shows no sign
of stopping they keep coming hungry and
terrify the hinges being loaded onto
these trucks and driven off to the camps
to a life of uncertain
[Music]
maybe yeah yeah maybe how old hotter
than here I still do eight days old yeah
this baby this baby hasn't even been
named yet born on the road to protect
his right now he's on his way to join a
new generation of stateless working your
children doomed spend the rest of their
lives in a foreign refugee camp
but despite the hardship they're about
to face these may be the fortunate ones
many reinga have died trying to make it
this far
[Music]
this body was found washed up on a beach
for days after a boat capsized
[Music]
it was carrying ringing your families
flings slaughter in Myanmar some 60 or
70 people were packed on board that boat
mostly women and young children these
are the traumatized survivors of that
perilous journey all from the same
village in Myanmar to evade border
guards the crossing was made in the
middle of the night the small wooden
boat was sailing and rough had my two
children on my lap when I saw the wave
coming I tried to pass one to my husband
but we got separated I was trying to
swim holding on to my seven-year-old son
he told me he couldn't swim anymore and
I had to let him go
because my youngest boy was swallowing
water then another wave hit us and that
separated me from my youngest child
another wave hit and we both went under
after we got separated I began looking
for him under the water I came up for
air and after a while his dead body
floated up in front of me I could hear
my oldest boy calling out for me as he
was being swept away by the current both
my children died
[Music]
arafat armed' and muhammad have been
left orphaned by the wreck the boys have
lost everyone
[Music]
my mom dad brother and sister all got
separated in the water then my mother
found me and grabbed on to me but I told
her you're going to die and you'll drown
me as well then she let go and she
drowned and so too did the rest of our
family our maid was swept up to a nearby
mangrove he held onto a tree until he
fell asleep
his mother and sister drowned Mohammed
hasn't seen his parents again he
survived by floating on top of a dead
body that drifted into Shore
[Music]
the widows and orphans of that boat
wreck have come here to cut the belong
camp to somehow try and rebuild their
shattered lives but there are so many
traumatized people here all trying to
wake from their nightmares
they've seen their families drown or
butchered their villages razed to the
ground and their women and girls preyed
on by predators in univille women like
Shazia and Rabia who was stripped beaten
and raped at gunpoint
just for being a ranger in men they came
into the village shooting at us we had
our money and jewelry inside pockets and
our dresses they stripped us naked and
stole everything and this was in front
of everyone if you want to see I can
show you our pockets where we hid our
valuables actually they came in groups
and one or two stood guard while the
rest went into the houses to violate the
other women that was really boring on a
dead-end 11-1 grabbed my hand and took
me to a path between some trees and
pushed me order nothing I fell down and
then he began raping me right here on us
the death I started to scream but then
another soldier came and pointed a gun
at me
would it hurt a kid would deliver there
but my yard I require shared you go do a
large number of soldiers came and they
tortured and raped whoever they could
catch what they have done to us I can't
even begin to tell you yeah and the love
will yard Appalachia I escaped the
forest after our village was burnt down
they found me there alone it's rare for
aid agencies to accuse a state of rape
but you and doctors working inside
Rohingya refugee camps reported hundreds
of cases during the first wave of
refugees last October and with this
recent influx
a lot of it that they're sure they I'd
the apology be because I was raped I had
to leave my country he got nothing
mother
our situation was bad before but we
stayed there has been violence for 12 to
15 years but we never left to become
refugees but this time when I was raped
I couldn't stay anymore and left with
nothing except for my clothes I'd this
cutting what can I tell you of the
torture this I've been through if I tell
you I will start crying we could not
tolerate the torture and misery anymore
and have to leave but we are uneducated
and illiterate and can't explain our
ordeal properly there is no peace for us
Shazia and Rabia not their real names
told us they want their story to be told
so others like them still inside Myanmar
might be saved and importantly although
persecuted by the outside world
these reinga women have not been cast
out from their community they think
that's because the attacks have targeted
so many of their women rape is being
used as a weapon against reinga women
and girls and those horrific accounts
that have been shared with us aren't
isolated cases it's happening on mass
what's really important now is that the
women who come to these camps find safe
refuge they must feel protected
during conflict rape is used as a
deliberate military strategy the Myanmar
army still denies its ethnic cleansing
but if it is ever held to account for
the atrocities committed inside Myanmar
the testimonies of these brave women and
other survivors could prove otherwise
widows like morena and orphans like
Mohammad are at high risk of
exploitation from trafficking gangs
they've experienced unimaginable horror
and are still suffering but now it's the
duty of the international community who
have failed a ring in the past to make
sure they are not failed again
[Music]